so if you have this sort of theory in
mind you can ask why do people from this
part of the world get a sense of comfort
and familiarity and
touching getting in touch with their
emotions when they go to the forest well
it's because their their system expects
this Forest to trigger those emotions
and then you can ask why does the forest
trigger those emotions well it's because
they have grown up in a culture and this
is very true if you're grown up in
Sweden where the school all the children
books every poet
musical text the general culture the law
the the curriculum for for Education all
of it tells this story again and again
and again